social security faces a massive funding
gap
but reform is far more than simply a
budget challenge
social security needs to work for
retirees the 21st century
so fundamental updates are needed social
security couples a transfer program to
poor retirees with a forced savings plan
for middle and high earners
this means it's neither as good a safety
net nor a savings program as it could be
my reform plan draws on the retirement
systems of other developed countries
to establish a true guarantee against
poverty in old age while encouraging
higher savings by middle and high income
americans
under my plan new retirees would receive
a minimum benefit
set at the poverty threshold meanwhile i
would gradually reduce the maximum
retirement benefit
until all retirees received the same
flat amount
automatic enrollment in an employer or
government-run retirement account
would boost benefits by a higher private
savings
my approach would cut social security
shortfall by three-fourths
and an independent study recently found
my plan would significantly boost
economic growth
versus progressives plans to expand
social security
do you think social security needs
reform let us know on our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei